here's lightning round you ready I'm
gonna give you a word a name and you
tell me the first thing that comes to
your mind okay or a little bit longer
than the first thing that comes to my
let's see what you're gonna say your
brain is a fast brain cease let's see
what you're gonna say first one Edward
Snowden Patriot really Ted Cruz Patriot
back to back Julian Assange Patriot
Bernie Sanders vampire Putin nationalist
beta beta is the one that's going
against a mental mental [ __ ]
Bill Gates eugenicist Elon Musk a scared
man really LeBron James [ __ ] Colin
Kaepernick [ __ ] Steve Bannon traitor
David Brock vampire Hillary Clinton
vampire Barack Obama vampire Bush
vampire Trump next slow
did you say next level next level
Moses Trump is Moses oh yeah elaborate
that wouldn't mean by Trump as Moses
he's the real friggin do my God knows it
that's all clear he's he's Pro him and
he wants progress he is one of just he's
our had everything and he's he's dialed
in to the real deal I guess they call
that the liver Trump's the deliverer if
we take it we've already seen it I've
already seen everything suppressing us
and then as soon as he comes in grass
and flowers and powers everything's
waiting right now Alex assume anybody
there that the decision-maker is
watching this I'll give you two final
thoughts what are you thinking about
right now you have the platform you have
the audience what would you like to say
I'd say that decision-makers are already
watching
I think the decision-makers already know
the choice they're just afraid to stand
up to this anti human thing and they're
afraid that the public isn't willing to
make the right decisions but that's what
leadership is about and
so people have to decide which side
they're on I mean this is like a big
spacewalk they say those astronauts walk
out and the space station or from the
space shuttle it's like you're looking
down the earth ten thousand miles
looking infinity and it's like they said
it doesn't like it and that that's it
you have to believe in humanity and if
you just do that everything else follows
so that's it then that's why they don't
like me you guys had question over and
over again is because I don't fear them
I've already been around a bit
I've already seen where it goes and
that's scary because they've not been
that but there will be there soon enough
they're gonna meet their maker and
they're gonna face God all right I with
pure consciousness and they're gonna
have to decide who they serve